après environ six mois de fermeture
c'est enfin le retour sur les planches
un soulagement pour les comédiens du
cabaret du bout des prêts ce samedi 26
septembre
c'est l'ouverture le spectacle raconte
l'histoire de mario un pizzaïolo qui
tombe amoureux de la lide danseuse au
cabaret ça faisait vraiment du bien sûr
dépenses et puis d'avoir encore le
contact avec tous les copains danseurs
danseuses qui nous a tellement manqué là
c'est génial puis pour la scène c'est un
peu une drogue donc voila quand on en a
plu pendant six mois mais c'est un peu
compliqué
la troupe a appris début septembre la
date de réouverture ce qui bloquait les
conditions de jeu sur scène
distanciation social masques et nombre
de comédiens sur les planches
tout était compliqué à mettre en place
le spectacle a été modifié depuis la
saison dernière avec plus de chansons
des années 60
[Musique]
j'étais impatient en tout cas après
toute cette période de pouvoir pouvoir
revenir ici et se remettre au boulot oui
c'était remis au boulot avant
télétravail v2 de se remettre au boulot
encore une fois face aux gens avec eux
pour les faire travailler les faire les
faire évoluer
est-ce qu'ils puissent se magnifier eux
mêmes dans cette pièce le spectacle sera
en représentation jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2020 une année particulière car
le cabaret il fêtera ses 10 ans